I think people maybe in my opinion were
unfairly upset over I mean how many
people have written in a nom de plume
and you've talked about this and avatars
in this day and age of social media we
all kind of have this alter ego and if
that's what you needed to express this
story this sometimes I think that
comments in an article
are more fascinating than the article
itself so it was a con aimed at the
publishing industry
it was the writer taking control instead
of letting the publishers take control
or advantage of the writer but if
shyness was partly the reason for the
con can't she be forgiven well the thing
is I don't like the word con like I
don't like the word hoax I never said
I'm gonna burst onto the literary scene
I was in and out of institutions I was
in a group home I was in foster care I
was a ward of the state this is all out
there in the public record because I
went through a trial and it was all
substantiated he went through everything
and it's all there and someone can do
the research so you don't have to take
my word for it
there are interviews with people who
were there in the group home with me who
were my house parents doctors who were
my therapist in my social worker all of
that and the getting published was the
least of it I never actually ever asked
someone hey can you help me get a book
deal I never did that never happened the
work was passed on and JT was offered a
book Dale offered an agent it never even
occurred to me it really was like very
accidental but I wanted to do was go
artist to artist with people I admired
and that all of this happened I couldn't
do it any other way it was not possible
as a very young child I just associated
and I told these stories in a male voice
and it was the way I self soothed and
that was where I instead of maybe become
a psycho killer I became a storyteller
and they just the need to interact with
other people where you know harvest
Darger the painter with his Vivian girl
he kept his world internal he just would
paint these portraits of these girls
that were like his Barbie doll portraits
and it was enough for him to keep it for
himself mine needed interaction with the
outside world mine needed someone to
tell them that it wasn't their fault but
of course it couldn't be me because they
wouldn't tell that to me because I had
so much shame I would never ever tell
anyone the little times that I did start
to talk about what was going on I didn't
get that help that I wanted so all of
this came out the way an oyster creates
a pearl out of suffering that creates
his pearl that's valued so it wasn't a
con on the if people want to say it was
this fantastic thing that I pulled over
that was not my intention and I think
that after the reveal or my outing the
media didn't step back and say well why
would somebody go to this extreme to do
all this
nobody really looked and I think I
didn't help the situation because I dug
in the trench like everyone who was
writing fake memoir and my work was
always published as fiction it says
fiction all over it you know when the
fake memoir people and I I don't care
about labels so I'm not judging them but
what people would do they would say look
we're on to you we know the whole truth
they would call a press conference and
they would say okay I'm not really a
pigmy from Antarctica you got me I
apologize I'm sorry I'm going to rehab
which is the American narrative right
I'm sorry I'm going to rehab and I
didn't do that because for me if you
took him I would die so I dug in deeper
against all logic because I couldn't
imagine it's the Tinkerbell thing how
can you
it was fighting for my child for this
beings life so I created kind of like a
severe Jean Valjean kind of limb as a
Rob's situation of hunting and that
makes people mad so the media wasn't
they were mad and they their language
perpetrate our hoax the jig is up come
clean culprit it was very much a
criminal like robbed a bank sold crack
to children kind of language that was
used and that created the echo chamber
and so people who read works that
invited them to be very vulnerable and
perhaps we stimulate their own trauma
which is what I was exploring in my work
they were told that what opened them was
a joke or a hoax and that creates a
trauma of itself and not only that is
they felt attached to this being that
I've murdered
I've killed JT and it was a joke and
they're being told that I'm laughing at
them and I've pulled something over oh
but it was a great wonderful con that's
horrible that's horrible nobody wants to
feel that so it took it had to take time
for the dust to settle and and then
what's beautiful is the felt
authenticity of the work survived what I
gave myself over to and what's available
there and people came back to it and
said wait there's more to the story
which is what happened with Jeff
you